come ci siamo conosciuti
Dai dai amore racconto io racconto io Va
bene io ero uscito una relazione che mi
aveva devastata psicologicamente proprio
non avevo nessuna intenzione di
fidanzarmi Poi però
è arrivato il signorino che mi ha fatto
scoprire cos'è l'amore vero mmm
amore e niente Allora praticamente
eravamo a cena andranno presentato io
sento come una scossa fortissima però
non ti ho non ti ho cagato difficile
quella sera veramente ti faccio un po'
sostenuta il giorno dopo mi stonano a
casa apro la porta c'era lui con 150
rose e un cartellone con scritto Vuoi
essere la mia principessa
io morta Sciolta da quella sera siamo
andati a convivere e domani tra l'altro
festeggiamo due settimane insieme Hai
detto che tra poco mi chiedo di sposarlo
Io voglio maschera femmina Niente amore
così da donne